how's compresses pimp I'd welcome to
hell today we're gonna talk somewhere to
my boo Jessica whoo that's what I call
her now we have three more locations to
chat with Jessica this game is called
don't be never to talking to girls if
this was actually how girls talk to me I
would be [ __ ] terrified of women oh
that concert was so awesome don't you
think so it's against my principles to
say totally but dammit for sure see you
later
oh I'm sorry I wasn't excited enough for
you yeah it's cause I've seen my goddamn
9200 eases the best fans hunters Hunter
Yves I'll walk with you okay what's with
the patronizing tone we're we're we're
was hundred mm and a real band the band
has less than a thousand plays on
Spotify I'm pretty sure anyone who plays
this game doesn't know where the [ __ ]
hunter Yves is frog goddess get pissed
me off yeah that's right I'm just gonna
go with a how do you get to know them if
you don't know the names I hate her I
fake tears that was goddamn awful I hate
her even more now all right now we're
going to the office I'm full chicken
forty for the full time what a manager
Wow water manager what are you waiting
for get me my water never seen a woman
so excited for water hold on you forgot
to tip me oh so I'm supposed to tip the
water manager
don't eat yellow snow thanks I hope you
choke in your water how many phone
sisters woman have how many goddamn
telephone numbers that she need what
no no average needed a Oh God
no no ha ha ha I have to replay every
one of them and get a perfect score
alright
challenge accepted
[Music]
yes right I'm coming for you Jessica
[Music]
oh yeah last map the airport how will
this breathtaking story end
hey what's your flight delayed excuse me
can you leave your baggy over there and
attended to what
please do not talk to me you slimy
sleazeball after all we've been through
why did why did she get so upset I don't
like huh how does anyone dare to talk to
this woman excuse me you can't leave
your bag over there unattended who are
you security why do you care why are you
so me there's like way less plane
crashes than car crashes okay you have
to be relatable I know this now Lucy I
this game has teach me the ways of the
wind relatable what okay don't do the
whole say whatever I want to hear
routine frankly I don't care what scares
you you don't make any any sense I
thought there was at least some pattern
to this game at this [ __ ] point I'm
trying to get your number
not to calm you down oops sorry about
that I don't know I don't i wouldíve now
if you knew what was good for you I know
karate and I can knock you out in a
second you wish
that's totally creepy you're creepy and
you make me feel sick in my mouth
I'm just gonna go and cry after tears
anger suffering we finally beat the game
old gray day what do we get
[Music]
nothing [ __ ] nothing we learned a lot
today
not to play shitty games like this but
I'll be watching if you did go ahead and
hit that like button down there and I
will see you too thank you for watching
and I will see you in the next
[Music]